alright also in the AFC North you've got
the team that nobody is paying attention
to the Cincinnati Bengals and Joe Mixon
who has become a very good running back
and only a couple of years in the NFL he
entered with some some controversy after
the way things happened for him in
Oklahoma with that vicious punch I think
the day he arrived on campus there was a
female he was arguing with and and the
cameras caught him just like a Ray Rice
style knockout punch and he's overcome
that he stayed out of trouble and he
believes the Bengals are gonna surprise
a lot of people this year and you know
what I'm not ready to sign on to it it
won't shock me if it happens because one
of the key ingredients in being a team
that can maybe surprise people is being
overlooked being a team that you get a
chip on your shoulder about that guys
start working harder and also they don't
have the burden of the extra pressure
that comes from being a darling like the
Browns do it's I know you can you can
get your guys amply pissed off and also
they don't get swollen heads until they
start winning football games and it
won't surprise me if the Bengals are
better than we expect them to be just
cuz we're not we have no expectations
for the Bengals issue yeah you're right
but I think they're on that like short
list of teams that I would have at least
like written down in a corner in a
notebook somewhere to go ooh watch out
these could be the surprise teams of
football I know you and I both like the
Jets and Bill's along that lines I of
course I think the Jacksonville Jaguars
it would be a team where I'd go watch
out for them this year and the
Cincinnati Bengals that won't be a
surprise I know but some people I have I
have friends ask me who should I watch
out for this year and I go I'd watch out
for Jacksonville I know it may be not
for you and me or you and me because
we're like in the woods in the weeds
with football all day long and and we
get it but I think some people in the
public have forgot about it so I know
but I'm just saying those are the teams
I would say to watch out for for big
turnarounds from where they were last
year this bangles team three things that
jump out to me first of all overlooked
like you said certainly can play into
okay we want to prove people wrong new
energy in the building that's a real
thing when you get a new head coach new
bosses new people it's fresh it feels
good you want to impress your new bosses
so everything's kind of tie
up that way that can lead to more wins
and the bottom line is the Bengals have
some talent at some key positions I mean
they got weapons on offense they got a
pie off quarterback they've improved
their old line
they got Geno Atkins and Carlos Dunlap
and ray Kirk fact Kirkpatrick and and
and William Jackson who I think is one
of the five or six best corners in
football so yeah I would not be shocked
if there are certainly a pain in the
butt to most teams in the AFC we talked
about this during the show today as it
relates to between the Jets and bills
whether one of those two teams can rise
up and contend for a wild-card berth
what a scramble it is going in writing
you you could make an argument that any
of the four AFC North teams or at least
any of the three that don't win the
division will be in the mix for wildcard
broke any of the three teams in the AFC
South that don't win the division can be
in the mix for wild-card berth AFC West
between the Broncos and the Raiders I
feel like one of them is not going to be
as bad as they were last year right you
throw them in with the Raider or the
charges excuse me in the Chiefs you gave
these not enough playoff spots to go
around they're talking about expanding
the playoff field maybe they should
write maybe it should go to 16 teams or
at least 14 teams because there's a lot
of good teams out there that aren't
gonna make it to the playoffs yeah well
I mean there are a lot of good teams out
there that aren't gonna make the
playoffs as of June what is this today
stay June 11 so you know and I know
we're you and I were excited about a lot
of teams you know outlook and the what
it looks like on paper but yeah we got
to see what it looks like but you're
right it seems like the AFC
at the very least has unbelievable
quarterback play that's where I look at
the AFC young quarterbacks old
quarterbacks they got it all and yeah I
mean we didn't even go into the AFC East
with like the bills and Josh Allen and
Sam darn old okay those are two guys we
could go they explode onto the scene
this year all of a sudden those teams
are back in the playoff conversation so
should be a fun year I think we all know
who the lead dog is in the house in New
England it's just gonna be whose two
three four or five and six after that
but you're right here's what happens and
and the biggest factor is injury we
don't know who we don't know when we
don't know how long they're gonna be out
we don't know how the replacements gonna
do but injuries will dramatically alter
the fortunes of some of these teams that
we look at right now as being good team
and you by Halloween was like yeah
forget it that team yeah it works itself
out and I've said this recently if every
team had Bill Belichick and Tom Brady
and the rest of the Patriots roster
there would still be a team that's
twelve and four and a team that's four
and twelve because the bounce of the
ball is going to determine a lot of the
outcomes of these games injuries luck
bad calls
that's how sometimes good teams separate
from bad teams and it can still be a
good team at 6 and 10
but your record says you're a bad team
so I don't know how good you think you
are
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports